hey we are back pound cake union or II
don't not too loud Sorry Sorry Sorry
head is a little a little a little still
in the clouds will still in the mud I
don't what's the best way to put that
cloud mud oh gosh tag cloud mud what a
great great another great gala and the
fact that we pulled off to galas in one
season yeah of a show we've never done
that before well I you know we're back
and I think that I think that that's you
know maybe that's a testament to it we
try it we're ready to get after it I n
you run a lot of that gala stuff and
maybe you're you know not drinkin yeah
makes you a little bit more effective I
getting those things done yeah I was
having fun with the live tweet I was
worried about that many people being in
a conference room style atmosphere
couldn't they would be hey got a room I
thought people might well I mean we're
still trying to pay off the invoice for
the last gala so we can't we can't do
that sighs again but we had about that
many people mm-hmm even though it was
invite only and we actually did too many
invites yeah it's supposed to be an
elite kind of thing will you figure some
we're gonna flake out on you but and I
kept here in the term ass to ankles
whereas the ankles yeah but people
watched people Dave watch because of the
live tweet nobody out of 10,000 nobody
liked the show which is not good numbers
for them but everyone loved the live
tweet and it was kind of uh it's it's
kind of bittersweet when you think about
it you know what I mean
what is this just another Oh Pete oh
listen old there's an old thing oh I
remember this one
I should say because because we're a
auto show all the Counting Crows let me
hold on let me finish because we're in
its not the counting crows oh I think
that was the kinds of friends band it's
called birds to hang out a brick group
of birds more than more than you can
count I think it was counting crows
because we're an audio show people will
have to just picture the montage of the
pound cake season so obviously picture
some fade in and fade out there's Marcus
upside down you're punching him can you
turn the music off though look at that
one that's me that's me doing a keg
stand oh you promised me you weren't
actually triggers another there's me
doing a shot oh there's a picture of
megan like a framed picture I guess it's
a picture of a friend looking behind
that picture I wish you i'm doing a
couple more shots so you turn off the
music though please do you want to get
sued I feel like you've replaced your
drinking addiction with a lawsuit
addiction and the fact that you think
I've replaced my drinking addiction is
insulting that night that it needs to be
replaced why i phrase that right yeah
I'm not drinking if that's what you're
getting you currently because I I got
tweets when I was looking for you last
night at the gala from the sack amazed
who said you were over at their table
ordering bottles and they did not want
to pay the bill I will say two things
about that first off that's on the
second base that is on the say you know
how i roll at these galas I wonder what
what's our motto what do we always say I
don't you kept asking me something if
you're not gonna be if you're gonna come
to a gala and you don't expect to pay ya
for I guess I don't even know the motto
no but what did you keep asking me last
night what if we got what if I got a
little while denying or something what
if I it was the end of that you want so
sad oh there's things I should know you
kept saying that they're it well every
friendship in relationship there's
things people sure you were very like
like you need to know something what was
I saying it like Anna back to the future
kind of way Marty's about to leave what
does he say no don't wait did I go
back I don't you die I I don't know but
I'm not worried about getting son ain't
wrong that is it he's saying that to
taliani the woman who plays his mom tale
leone doesn't play his mom yeah that's
pretty sure that's taliani it's leah
remini yeah from from Qing er getting a
good no yes dear she was in yes yes king
of castles remember when we did a [ __ ]
season of yes dear sorry FCC remember we
did yes dear no that was the year I let
you pick the show and you picked yes
dear which I thought was a ploy to make
me hate it so much I would quit oh yeah
I do remember do you even remember any
of it yeah you don't ok let's talk about
let's talk about the the James Franco
named elephant in the room ok the finale
of 11 22 63 it's been a journey huh I
mean I thought that it was
an adventure what is this back to the
future the soundtrack Leah Thomas let's
hoop Thompson Thompson yep are you sure
it's Leah though Leia yeah i think it
was Leia Leia tom princess tonight let's
look back I'm so yallah i just want to
say something to all the listeners i'm
so happy that we are done watching this
thing when we wanted to get pound cake
back together when you remember how
excited so excited we're back together
oh yeah I mean who is what needed to
happen has happened what the policy
things were both ignoring apologies that
needed to be emailed to each other were
emailed and then sort of said without
words first a foul on a new radio
station now everything is great on a
radio place all things comedy it's the
first time I've been on a radio station
that doesn't have call letters this is
2016 like it is this in the days of yore
I guess you're right you know well I
wrote let's be frank mm-hmm eight weeks
ago nine weeks ago we are we a story
yeah I mean we had both read this book
independently it was part of what
brought us back together yeah and we
were so excited to jump on board what we
thought would be you know I don't expect
it to be Fargo level we weren't together
then but if you watch season one or two
I only ever watch whatever we're
analyzing what I thought you liked TV
yeah I love it big TV person but you
don't watch it if we're not doing the
show that's how big of a TV person I am
I'm that committed to specific
television what am I going to cloud my
mind without what else is out there or
do I want to focus specifically on what
I am analyzing I would be doing would
you watch the whole time we were apart
sports i will watch sports all I love
sports speaking of sports yeah we'll get
back to what I was saying yeah last
night guys everybody who was there
understood they were there with us
crammed into that hotel bar we had to
watch the end and I want to say this of
the
there were two hotel bars I thought
Daniel and I were in the exact same bar
we're texting I'm not responding he's
not responding I thought he was in the
but I was on I was a little drunk I'll
be honest I was on the chapel hill north
carolina bar side team stream yeah
watching that channel yeah on that
channel they won the game no they know
I've actually melanoma team stream well
that's how it works that team stream
thing everybody where lie no one on the
team stream oh it's like a participation
trophy to ya hit that double pump
three-pointers away when you were
watching yeah just he he missed the
final thing Wow yeah Jordan Michael
Jordan was happy and he was happy in his
clothes and all his glory and all 1,500
alum you know brushed the floor yeah it
was quite something Wow and when did you
find out that that wasn't what actually
happened once I got back into the gala
to listen to so de Sade's snorefest
we'll get into that let's do it all
right now anyone i just read a poem okay
so we pick up where Jake and Sadie are
what would you say two and a half miles
from the Book Depository you would think
but in this particular episode with how
far he's driving how fast they were 30
minutes outside of town yeah I think he
was like you know here we are the cop
told us we can't be here tonight sure so
we'll skedaddle out of here where should
we go let's just go back to Jodi I mean
they were got oh they were so far away
and then he gets uh they get into a bus
nothing can go wrong there right and
they get ran in Dubai a car was that guy
drunk what was that guy's story I think
he was just the past well maybe he was
leave on that team so maybe he was on
the van der team van der beek straight
life yeah that's a good point I tried to
team stream ville I try I tried to team
stream 11 22 63 last night how to self
it would just be the book
in it just they don't offer that oh
would ya yo new team stream for shows
more choose your own adventure style
television ask you a question yeah not
enough deke in the final up son where
was dig you kept saying it where's d
well we'll get to the part where you
said it and where's gate we'll get to
the part where you said it okay so they
get knocked to get into a bus accident
right running and then so far and they'd
it's decide to jump into a bus when it
looks to me like they were literally
around the corner yeah from the Book
Depository because you said is they went
through that Tony like it's right there
it's that is the underpass we saw the
zip Reuters is it Zapruder Zapruder soup
reuters this was just him no I don't
think that was a there was a woman next
to me I don't think was a family man it
was a mistress that's the one thing that
you can that's why he's so shaky with
that tape do your research go to
Wikipedia calm folks and check it out
Zapruder cheated on his wife and his
family and was a member of the Nazi
Party really go to go to Wikipedia so
the past seems to have left itself back
at the bus crash because when Jake and
Sadie get to the Book Depository a nice
young gentleman who works there doesn't
want to let them in yeah but he gives it
up pretty easy yeah so the past just
stopped when they get to the one place
they need to be yeah pass was like
that's fine and all the doors will be
unlocked what are we gonna do he's come
this far we're the past yeah that just
let him go right Oh garbage just like
garbage I just thought of something yeah
do we have to apologize for james Van
Der Beek saying [ __ ] JFK apologies to
the FCC can you look into that I'll
guess ok course therefore so you'll
handle that legal I got a great so
taking a drinker i need so much water
from after you don't look well last
night sorry up Stacy um they get in the
Book Depository Lee doesn't stop
shooting for anything people are yelling
his name wouldn't you think that throw
you off your game right Lee stop
struggle ensues yeah here's my question
did in in in real life you know
did the first bullet hit Kennedy like
the back right because you see him on
the superb no jeff says no no also it so
the first shot mr. three shots or total
fired in history one I think did one
like go through him and then through the
governor's hand and that's the magic
bullet the second shot well you said
there was a magic bullet in this episode
there was and what is it Sadie how'd she
get hit then what happened the bullet
just went around all the books what I
feel like the first shot that Lee fired
at them and they jumped out of the way
you could have had Jake's a CD are you
okay she says yes just stop Lee yeah and
then we cut back to her and sewing that
she didn't want to tell him she had been
hint right much stronger death in my
opinion you and and and everyone in the
pound cake Union you know dan always
goes for stronger death yeah so then the
typical score that we always do when it
comes to ultimate deaths of a main
character on a scale of one to three
where did you find Sadie's death hmm
we'll see it's hard because I'm
comparing it with the book well I always
go to because that's such a neutral for
one two three I thought was at to style
death I'm gonna give it a one but only
and I'm admitting that I can't not
compare it to the book did it did you
cry when she died no well do we'll cover
this in the book episode yeah that makes
sense yeah um so she's laid out right
right dead Jake and just wants to keep
yelling help her someone help her help
her help her someone help her no one
cared about Sadie no at all no nobody
cares about leave for that matter there
was uh it's just really foggy to me I
apologized I was drinking a lot yes well
he's just said apologized no guys still
in my system apologize what's there a
scene where Lee's mom was talking to the
news reporters yeah she was like my son
has done more for the country then the
guy who tried to kill the president yeah
did she say son or my boyfriend I
I don't know get it okay so yellow card
man doesn't show up at all this is the
music that was going on during the the
Book Depository see really Lee wait lai
lai lai don't you get away from me Shh
oh no I'm sorry he's faced maybe they're
coming back with some lunch for me
minions my friends you have lund you
should get away from me Leigh we got you
something from checkers we got you
checkers chicken bites I don't want them
yeah well we also got a cheeseburger if
you're willing to consider that
cheeseburger is better but I don't want
to tease look don't kill the president
and only eat this burger oh I have to
kill it then can you leave it out maybe
put a part of the microwave so I can eat
it up ever I shoot the president so what
do you think that was me doing james
franco and leave me heart lee harvey
oswald what do you think that was great
i pulled off the russian and i was able
to switch back yeah that was phenomenal
that is good right now I've always the
hoist food yes ok a sober Rory is a good
Rory are you sober right now ah ok ah
then Jake gets interrogated yeah in 1963
can you talk to cops like that and an
FBI errs and did the press just as good
get to go wherever they wanted in any
police station they were friends they
were buddies back there's a wonderful
series of blinds being shot all around
them shut that blind shut these wives
over here you know my favorite part is
and you said this last night in the gala
I think you're on probably don't you all
you're on your 14th vodka soda those
things do labs those things go down yeah
I would you know looks like water goes
like water you said good thing we met
Ruby that was good it was good that he
was a part of the story ever and yeah is
that just for fun there was a part where
I turn to you and said hey it's jack
ruby gonna kill him yeah because why did
we meet Jack Ruby they were setting it
up like like that's what was gonna
happen do you think they yet did I think
they shot that jesting so they had that
option like how much do we want to screw
up this book maybe they were alike
let's set it up so people think that
might happen you know I mean let's let's
tease it how many people do you think
we're paying that close of attention is
you and I I think knuckle pop and the
sack amazed little kisses dr. little
kisses kisses tickles um folks we're
still pushing hard for hashtag canceled
a Riley com apparently she's still out
there so and you told me that by the end
of this episode you're announcing a
winner for the t-shirt I didn't I
thought you said you would have you had
it or made up on you take this out maybe
by the book episode no I never dad I
never got a t-shirt I never gotten one
of the t-shirts you said you this is
what you this is like the big thing
you've promised people I'm all I mean
people were going in and out of Jeff you
heard him he promised it right I mean we
cut all this out yes or no Jeff people
yeah exciting your breath and that's a
for chocolate frosted pancake what kind
of a Satan worshiper sends that here's
my thing people were going in and out of
participating we don't have to wait look
but I called you that you made the
stipulations way too high but you kept
promising that oh they're in any way oh
there's another round I'm gonna give it
away by the end of the show I was
kidding you never said JK I'll gotta go
JK JFK I'll pick just [ __ ] kidding
Jeff go back in and retro actively put
us laughing in oh that's good
camaraderie JFK is backed by educating
sorry em season oh we're back at um we
were talking about something that's here
nor there uh Rory I said we just kiddin
it's a JFK just [ __ ] kiddin and it
just it lit up this place Markus is on
the floor like I don't even know where
did you go home with that coat check
girl I don't think he's breathing that
might Marcus Marcus oh no I saw him
twitch oh we're good hey when you wake
up [ __ ]
sorry sec tell us if you went over that
coat check girl if you guys are gonna
see a picture the coat check girl head
on over to our Instagram and try to get
that one 30 other followers to get on
the Instagram that's from the gal of the
first gal who knows who we ran into last
night so Rory do we do we have a big
announcement about the contest at the
end of this show for both we've yet to
talk about you're gonna announce it on
the book episode the winner the winner
is gonna be announced on the book
episode no no JFK n-no JFK and this time
there's gonna be a winner announced on
the book episode oh okay and that's
something we can you gotta tell me you
gotta tell you shut down that was that's
something that we'll just figure as we
go we'll figure it out we have a couple
days more nobody knows our address work
dude we gave out the address you gave
out the address last time and i'm sure
all they have to do is look up radio
stations all things comedy we're gotta
be listed in like a radio station
directory don't like it dirt like a
yearbook yeah good radio station
yearbook yeah we have to be did you have
you remember when we used to be we had
to be back in yet I don't even know I
don't know well here I here's my thing
let's come back in um we'll just come
back in when we want to come back and
jeff's have us come back down this Oh
hey Daniel did you remember those radio
yearbooks we used to have off yup you
got it all right what when when suit man
here's my question how did you're gonna
jump way too far gone how did James
Franco Jake how did he know that that
guy's superior was about to walk in and
say that is that just noted in history
that that guy walked in in a couple
minutes and said no waste Roy that
letter how did he know that there's no
way he should have known and also why
would someone walk in and go hey I
realized there's a guy here but I'm
gonna have this how did Jake business in
front of this guy how did Jake know that
Lee had even gone to the FBI office and
ripped a pen off the desk oh did he say
there was a yeah he went in and made a
proclamation and wrote that down that's
the letter you're talking about he
didn't mentioned i think maybe that's a
known thing in history I don't think
that really happened in real life auj
and me I think it did happen I think
your jf candies in parkland it's in
parkland so it's in parkland is that
some sort of amusement that's a movie
Jeff you can back me up on this right
sparkling a movie Jeff oh Jesus Christ
are you yawning he was yawning eating
stop it you're taught you're eating I'm
Mike your mic still on marques don't
come back to the show did you have sex
with that coat check girl thumbs up from
Marcus yeah Marcus loves those coat
checkers yeah hi cuz i always find candy
and the coats um yeah Jayd cataria
thought about that there's gonna be so
much presses everywhere then Jake makes
the the long long road that back to
Lizard in Maine Lisbon got to get
through right gotta go see what the 2016
looks yeah and he goes through and what
does he say dan [ __ ] have another diner
what the [ __ ] happens sec sorry hunter
so I FCT what the [ __ ] sorry yeah I love
I don't know why I was better all right
let us know on Twitter guys yeah and
guys tweet at us and try to get 30
people to follow us if you want to go on
to the next round of the and I don't
know what this means here taken they are
they they hand me this piece of paper
from all things common it says please go
and review the show that's probably some
sort of radio website or something
review the show give us five stars and
leave it leave a review yeah yeah yeahs
on the radio drawer happy to be on this
radio stations on the radio director
I'll call owners for some weird reason
haha another dine SIA SIA um your turn
honey yeah Once Upon given to the diner
I know I'm not as good as you but it's
not bad right wonderful having to the
diner what the [ __ ] happened of the day
and I know what this is my buddy's band
this is no way lose your butch ones your
buddy d Daryl all know there's Askins
he's not in this band and Jason admire
no those are not the people in the band
it's daryl hall & john oates who wait
what did I say John I Meyer Joan are a
liar and I don't have David Haskins no
that is not is this their cover band
hashtag David hask haskins hashtag Jason
ah Meyer I know this song yeah this is
maneater by daryl hall & john oates x is
it John probably sounds similar they
have similar names so obviously the
music would sound the same I was again I
was just basic math I was gonna give
Jeff an opportunity to say it you don't
want him to say it we say what sorry
Susan what if he's really saying I
apologize in advance FCC I've seen her
for me really sorry yeah and and and
[ __ ] just [ __ ] kidding what if that's
what he say in [ __ ] just [ __ ] sorry
FCC for what I said Rory sorry
absolutely um Jeff give it a shot Oh
where's whatever the diner oh my god
that was horrible how do you want I
don't know damn it in his maybe in his
maybe he was watching the chew stream of
11 22 °c for you what were you doing at
the gala were you I know really saw you
did you see like a wedding and
a wedding reception there was a separate
side table that people had put pound
cakes on top of that started after 20
minutes and I don't even remember it was
disgusting look what you showed up
wasted Jeff I see grab a couple of
layers into the Nova the the Nova team
stream I don't even know if he even
watched the show last night well I mean
if he which is a strange dedication
since it was a gala for us yep he
probably doesn't even care once he if he
got his pound cake that pound cake nut
that's all you know it's not tired of
eating [ __ ] FCC his emotions because
that's what he's eating yes that is true
but I don't understand how you can
possibly eat that much sugar the crazy
thing is he looks great it's his doctor
told him though this is going straight
to your arteries right he doesn't care
he'd mainline it if he could what
mainline it pound cake yeah like how
people do with heroin good I mainline
heroin that's [ __ ] right so Jake makes
his way back he goes to the most
inattentive bus uh like bus what do you
call it like ticket salesman at the bus
station at night crazy huh they stood
there for 20 seconds watching TV before
the guy goes gonna good i hope you're
something wait yeah I want a goddamn
ticket man yeah to Lisbon I want to go
to Lisbon he gets to live but I don't
want your life but I don't want your
life they with the bus guy goes the bus
guys hey where you going and he goes I
need a ticket to Lisbon he's like tell
you what I don't want but I don't want
your life that's a long bus ride about
Dallas to Lisbon but I don't want your
lies that bill that's bill right bill a
tourney oh you're doing over there build
turncoat so it's turcotte Trickett all
of a sudden Jake says what happen to the
[ __ ] diner what sorry I'm sorry sec
he's in some sort of walking dead yeah
uh Lisbon main scenario yeah and he
meets the Highlander aka Harry Dunning
that's right whoo-hoo way we thought was
Neil Young yes
Young was saved I remember now you sang
who is that I like a young yeah and we
were like oh my god it took us so long
to be like oh yeah Harry from the
beginning yeah yeah you think we would
have got what now what if Jake had just
said to himself hair are you dumb and
here we go no I'm fine my somebody
killed my dad was there there was worth
it yeah he was like worth it wouldn't
you have loved if Jake was just like
worth it worth it i'll figure out my
life ares got his own place to himself
he's got a whole bunch of knickknacks
around he's just waiting for the
american pickers to come and help clean
this place out you know what jig didn't
do he didn't do any research to see if
the rest of the world was fantastic like
maybe yeah what are you here he was
lying what holy Lisbon was shitty would
you give up Lisbon main for a better
world you know how many people he gave
I'm traveled back to Detroit and they
were like oh my god I gotta go reset
like now everyone else is fine right
it's just a Troy it's just Detroit Bush
tried to give up New Orleans exactly so
we wouldn't give up Lisbon main exactly
couldn't give up a Lisbon man hashtag
cancelled a Riley doctor hope that
didn't know that was coming how you
didn't know that was tagged well I'm
sorry was that the sauna play David
Haskins and John at meijer JS gym yeah
Donna and you're telling me you promised
me that's who's singing that song I'm
not gonna hear from daryl hall or John
Oates reuven guard why do you care why
do you honestly [ __ ] care we're all
right we're working for a radio stations
a [ __ ] we're gonna get [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Roy
ashtag ah [ __ ] the pound cake hashtag
[ __ ] on the pound cake say you're sorry
to the FCC yes I know you said you know
what I'm gonna let this part slide good
I'm we're sorry FCC I'm speaking for
Rory Scovel when he says I'm sorry okay
um so some reason then we wouldn't want
a jail game yeah JFK put people in a
concentration camp some about that I
don't know Wallace became president I
don't know which
all of forest compass I vaguely remember
tweeting out something like that yeah
then you also had your assistant you
have a new assistant Timmy your new
assistant timmy was doing a lot tweeting
for you too so you should go back I
think some things were said I don't
remember hiring anybody named Tim you
have a new assistant named Timmy that's
working for me you introduced him last
night oh yeah so that's who gave me a
ride home I mean maybe you know what
you're kind of like Jake coming to
remember that he's in in town today's
the entire day's jello day today's jello
day I might jump out that window so in
order to reset everything Jake could
have just gone back in time turned
around but then he noticed someone in
that pink car do you know what Sadie the
whole time from the rebbe game I do yeah
yeah I do one little thing they put in
there I might go back he rushes into a
bum rushes her i say bum with intent
because he rushes into the diner tries
to flirt with her and then all of a
sudden yeah she's like oh I'm game and
they flirt after he what girl doesn't
want to go outside and talk to a guy
they've never seen before they're just
accosted them and then got in a fight
with a hole then went outside to fight a
hobos i'm gonna go i'm gonna make sure
that guy knows my name and that I'm in
town for a little while yeah I need to
go make sure that guy knows I'm not I'm
not leaving I felt rude yeah not chasing
after ya immediately and then uh Jake
leaves comes back in time and says ona
look cold Sadie up old old nan Scarface
ad up there was one line that could have
been said in this episode that would
have made me say i love the entire mini
see what is that that is a jake going
resetting uh-huh chattin it up with
Said's face resets galore you finally
got your risa goes back to the 2016 that
we know yeah and he just immediately
goes there's the [ __ ] diner
sciences that would have a great there
it is that would have been great he
finds Sadie getting honored at some sort
of honoring thing Jubilee and Jodi or
some sort of deal i think i hope a lot
of people noticed that that was the
theme of the gala last night we said all
the tables up and everything to look
like that did anybody say anything to
you because if they said something to me
I don't remember nobody said anything to
me and I think I went unnoticed so I was
like wow I wanted on the show then yeah
we got working yeah bringing up on the
podcast radio program um she goes she
finishes her speech and you know you
think there'd be a lot of people that
want to talk to her nope she's alone
yeah Jake goes up to her very creepily
and then it doesn't answer all of our
questions like why do I think I know you
you would think that you would think
that you old [ __ ] yeah like if you were
to responded one time like that i go i
love this whole miniseries top to bottom
really just something weird toss in a
weird jay klein I've always said once we
kind of straight away from how with any
affinity for this show that I always
give credit where credit's due and the
very final moments were we're good it
was good see them dance like that you
know what I don't believe that those two
actors in that scene nor the actors
throughout the show ever really loved
each other which is kind of crucial to a
romance but I think the book helped me
appreciate the show in that moment this
is going to sound inconsistent with
everything I have set up until this
point but after now getting through it
and seeing how it all ties together I
liked the miniseries a lot i thought it
was very well done i thought i was very
well written and i will more than likely
go back and watch it again you're crazy
I'm sorry I yes intended I go that way
what's the way the doors closed at the
Anna's like what I finally realized and
it had a lot to do with saving speech I
was like oh oh yeah well no wonder loyal
SP i love that speech I was like oh no
wonder i was confused because what I
before I read a book but what I'm
getting to watch now is a poem yeah and
those aren't the same granted there are
books of poems and there's poems about
books but in the context i'm currently
talking about they're not i denied well
speaking of getting something now I have
a surprise what what is it well somebody
you got me something well somebody left
me a voicemail I haven't even listened
to it yet I thought we would listen to
it together is Ken reaching out to say
congrats who knows work ends at these
days Megan Amram what yeah man I had
been trying to get ahold of her for a
long time she finally just got talked to
her no she sent me this first of all I'm
sure it's her being like everything's
gonna get sorted out why didn't she call
me i Doan the one that was Ben I'm the
one trying to track her down I don't
have everything I know that you you've
told me numerous times at night and I
believe in you I'm just saying how great
is it gonna be to finally get to hear
from Megan well but I play it I'm
married are you as excited as I am yes
they do what if she's calling to say
guys it all got worked out i'll be there
i'm outside or I'll be there right now
hope hope that's what we're gonna hear
let's find out hey it's Meghan oh hey
hey yes be weird about this okay but I'm
obviously a huge fan of town cake horse
you are you were part of dead and I
heard through the grapevine the pound of
vine that you guys were doing shows
that's in me I'm Luna told her well I
love to bid on it what it's the last one
and you never asked me and I just think
that this one turd snub and I feel
really terrible about it so I just
wanted to call up you know pretty
low-key I just tell you I feel really
horrible about this she's leaving flying
voicemail that's inner that is a
inappropriate let this is a classic
Megan goon no it isn't a classic Megan
goose is a classic megan goof Roy she's
never even asked we've been going over
contracts for weeks and I've been
reaching out every episode I'm like a
ghetto she said she's
never even been asked right one hundred
percent obviously asked her what I'm
gonna do not ask her what am I gonna do
say it not ask her and then say I am
yeah yeah you never liked her are you oh
I loved Megan don't give it okay well
you're saying it past tense you're
saying any past tense look as I did love
her I haven't seen but why didn't you
ask her to be on the goddamn yester
she's joking that's a joke that is not a
joke that is sincere she finds my
corners I see her about playing again
bleh bleh oh no I will gladly play it
again this is it sounds like this or
just kidding at the very end she does
not Lacroix listen it's Megan area it's
not funny worried that she doesn't to be
weird about it lizzo ilysm fan of pound
cake I'm a really big pound head and I'm
all about it find the pound vine she
hurt guys we're doing that's funny I
shall in miniature and i would love to
bid on it how do you guys know edgy
christian so any never asked my buddy
you never asked me i asked her ok you
should've called you no call up you know
pretty little she better say JFK me
Laurel is about this so on thank you is
it coming because the message is over
Rory and she says you never asked me
she's been edited I don't know they do
you have an end my head I just played it
why would I do that I can't you tell me
why would she come on to those classic
Rory why whoa we're back on the saddle
yeah this is good we was good to show
the lawsuit Marcus is here oh ok yaps
over there yeah we got lawsuits galore
we have 17 lawsuit thank you very much
Rory and Megan's not is how many
lawsuits do we have here my gosh yet 25
or more what what Marcus one is no I
Marcus Marcus is Hannah me paper what is
this well yeah this says all things
comedy is not a radio station yes it is
he this says all things common incident
is
not sound like a radio ID know it I said
that numerous times I ATC you're
listening to ATC on 93 I don't know the
numbers there are no numbers it says we
are currently being broadcast on a
podcast network we have never been on a
radio station for the entire duration of
the show that's a classic Marcus goof
right there that's a goof Jeff I'm gonna
ask you and I want you to just tell me
the truth I will not put any of this
blame on you Jeff I all I want to know
is the truth Jojo get him you're still
gonna get pound cakes I will ensure that
dude all I want to know is the truth are
we currently right now on a radio
station no son of a [ __ ] Rory what what
have we not had fun and we not enjoyed
our low what is a podcast we have 200
followers on Twitter that is outstanding
work we usually have thousands okay oh
the next thing you're gonna tell me you
hired all those people to come to the
gala yeah this is so typical you this is
so typical you get drunk do a live tweet
yell at somebody watch Villanova win a
national champions all the same [ __ ]
every year every years the same thing
live tweet a thing get drunk at a gala
watch Villanova win ya know it is 1985
Omar and that was the last time I
trusted you how many how much money do
you have in our budget to hire a [ __ ]
assistant you hate him you're a charge
for Haley I'm talking about Timmy I
didn't get a newest I don't even
remember hiring tats how drunk you are
here's the alcoholic oh wow kahari I
threw a pebble with some mountain idea
the mountain is making the divorce bad
[ __ ] idea talking about you [ __ ] this
show [ __ ] you Jeff for getting involved
[ __ ] you Marcus you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] get back here lights get back here
table [ __ ] all things comedy yeah you
heard oak big man big man
no I don't give a [ __ ] no radio don't
worry about giving a [ __ ] about [ __ ] the
pound cake